if we continue down the misguided path
of the government is taking us then the
future does not look good I have Nikhil
SP for reason TV and we are broadcasting
from Freedom Fest in Las Vegas and right
now we're talking to Ben Powell he's an
economist and he's the head of the free
market Institute at Texas Tech in
Lubbock Texas Ben thanks for talking to
us thanks for having me the theme of
this conference is our we roam you have
talked a lot about Rome and what went
right and what went wrong in Rome's
first hundred years as an empire what
did Rome do that helped really juice its
economic advantage well actually what
helped of course juice its economic
advantage was actually not doing much so
during its first hundred years or so of
the empire under Octavian it was a
largely at a free trade area customs
duties were around 5% or so taxation was
very low and forget you know we talk
about like progressive taxation in the
United States they had ultimate
regressive taxation where provinces just
have to send a fixed amount of booty and
individuals just had a head tax so it's
not like a Steve Forbes flat tax of
whatever percent it's like you're alive
five thousand bucks so in the first
hundred years of the Roman Empire I mean
there's this broad pox Romana going on
and and Rome basically structured stuff
but you say within that anyway I mean
and that was an empire that was founded
upon kind of military might and police
power but within that it was largely
free market largely market orientated
it's not the same as what would consider
modern free markets say but largely
market oriented and to the extent that
you can gather evidence because it's
always sketchy when we're like Oh
economic growth from 3,000 years ago but
you can look at like shipwrecks and
during that first hundred you see tons
of shipwrecks that are discovered from
that time period which indicates there
was a lot of trade and commerce going on
so things are going well would what did
they do to screw it up maximum extent of
the Empire you get out to those limits
and how they finance a lot was booty
from abroad and once they got to the
maximum extent of their empire they
didn't have new people to steal from so
to continue to provide the free bread
the free grain that they did to put on
all the big shows they needed to tax the
Romans more so this was kind of like a
Hunger Games
area where they expand the borders or
the boundaries of their empire they get
more and more people kicking back to the
central district but then at a certain
point they've got to start taxing that
central district yeah and as they did
what happened is the central district
became a shell basically there was no
productivity going on the productivity
was outside and it was decaying as you
could not get more for actually it's not
unlike Washington DC if we wanted to
talk about decaying shell in the middle
that's sucking everything in and they
started you know doing the things that
governments in the last 2,000 years of
all - basing their currency raising
taxes eventually they collapsed their
monetary economy they went from
something that was 100 percent silver
down to one 5000 percent in the first
300 years and people just stopped using
the money so governments just directly
confiscated goods and gave it to the
government but you say also that I mean
over the course of the Roman Empire the
decline of the Roman Empire things got
better for the for individuals things
got worse for the individuals as their
big intrusive government was stepping on
the more and more so what you started
seeing was people actually leaving the
Roman Empire voluntarily to go among the
barbarians because life would be better
so ultimately when the Empire collapses
we tend to think of it Taylor oh the
Roman Empire collapsed civilization was
gone this is kind of like the the big
pile of stuff notion of history like
look the Romans built the stuff it must
have been good for them to live there no
for most of the people they had a
oppressive government that was stealing
lots of stuff so I mean it's kind of
like a living next to a
taxpayer-financed Stadium
it's great if you own the team but if
you're not into football but you're
paying for it it it it's just a big pain
in the butt yeah exactly so it you know
historians aren't known to be like free
market people but it's not tough to find
historians writing about the decline of
the Roman Empire and saying and when it
collapsed life was largely unchanged for
the normal room a normal citizen of the
Empire so are we Rome that's the large
theme of freedom Fest this year or what
what does that even mean how do you how
do you address that question it's up to
us of course is the main thing because
ideas or what matter so the United
States of course the you know it takes
23 dollars to buy today what it took one
dollar in 1913 so they've debase the
currency they continue to tax and become
more choose our economic freedom has
been plummeting the last ten years and
this isn't a product of like Obama it's
Bush Obama consistently more than half
of our decline in economic freedoms
happened under Bush it's just the rate
of decline is happening more under Obama
so it's really where do we go from here
if we embrace economic freedom and go
back in that direction we don't have to
be at all like Rome if we continue down
the misguided path of the government is
taking us then the future does not look
good thank you Ben Powell for talking
about Rome at the freedom fest
conference in Las Vegas in 2013 which
big title was are we Rome for reason TV
I'm Nikolas